ghostrider
really is about making new friends and
has characters coming to life from books
this is plastic goes behavior
I think it's really important for kids
to have a series that focuses on
literature different genres different
authors look
there are 10 books that are highlighted
Alice's Adventures in Wonderland I
demand you escort me to the Queen at
once
Frankenstein Trinity the jungle would my
fee I do not understand this new word we
can help with that let's start with
pants mm-hmm that I'm right
the idea of the show when you read a
book you actually interact with it it's
middle school these kids work really
really hard together as a team to solve
a mystery with some friendship and
persistence what better to empower them
to engage them and to trigger
young people's voices well
so actually inspired me to want to read
you don't know what's gonna happen next
it's so good it's a good old-fashioned
duel it's in every Western gosh you die
on you can it be after school
you